Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to the Outlast 2 demo.
Now I believe this is the same demo I played in PAX East but
I have this curse where every time I play a game no matter where I am
I inevitably find a way to break it and that happened when I was playing this demo
at PAX. So sorry to the developers and THANK YOU developers for getting me the demo. But either way;
"You are Blake Langermann, a cameraman working with your wife Lynn.
The two of you are investi-
[confused mumbling]
- investigative journalists willing to take risks and dig deeper
to undercover the stories no one else will dare to touch.
You're following a trail of clues that started with the
seemingly impossible murder of a pregnant woman known only as
Jane Doe.
The investigation has led you miles into the Arizona desert,
to a darkness so deep that no one could shed light upon it,
and a corruption so profound that going mad may be the only sane thing to do."
*Slightly disturbing laugh*
Okay. So I am unbelievab- *woman interrupts Mark*
[woman's voice over recording] [plane engine whirring]
[Man's voice, stuttering] Okay! Uh, w-we're good.
[woman's voice (again)]
*Shit goes down*
[sounds of panic, alarms beeping, rattling metal]
[sounds increase]
*Woman screams*
Mark: 0_0
Wow.
Yes. I'm very, very excited for this. The subtitles were a little off from the audio there
but that's okay.
I'm gonna make sure the settings are all good before I get started in to the actual game.
*character grunts*
[man from recording] "Lynn!"
Lynn?
Oh there I am.
Oh boy
Oh God
Now as far my understanding goes, I don't think that this is the character
that we're gonna be playing in actually Outlast 2
of which I am incredibly excited for because Outlast is just
a shining gem in the horror game genre.
I am super happy not only that is existed but that was amazing.
And even the expansion/DLC or whatever you wanna call it
Whistleblower, which was also very cool.
So
Welcome back everybody
Welcome back to OUTLAST
*Mark...grunts?*
You alright, buddy?
Yeah, walk it off.
Rub some dirt in it!
You'll be FIIIIINE...
Stitch up your broken leg with a few sticks.
alright
Right mouse button as per us[ual]
and the night vision has returned
So we just had some sort of uhh...plane accident?
and this is the husband of
of the wife, Lynn, that he's calling for
And that's all
very...
y'know...
not happy.
HELLO!
HI!
I seem to be in a spot of trouble. Can you help me?
Please?
Even though I hear flies in there, somehow.
Yeah, there's probably dead bodies in there...
I'M AN EXPERT ON KNOWING WHEN DEAD THINGS ARE IN PLACES!
And I'm pretty sure...
If I... zoom in there
That's PROBABLY blood.
...Probably.
...alright
I'LL LEAVE YOU ALONE, you seem to be busy.
Okay
Goodbye then!
Alright so like I said before
I did play this at PAX so I-
*rustling in the bushes*
HI!
I don't know if they've changed anything or updated it since then
I imagine they have because I broke it
Like I break everything in my life...
HELLO!?
Oh that's a pleasant-
[man's voice] "Is anybody there?"
Is anybody there?
"Please!"
Please!
Oh hey, dead guy! I'm whisper yelling!
Thank you, sir!
Have a...
lovely...
hey...
Ugh that's so weird, you can see the flies dusting around
on his face.
They're just textures that are bouncing around him.
*Mark le gasps*
Hello...
Hi?
Oh God damn it I stopped waving the flies away from my face.
Now in the demo I didn't take time to explore so that's what I'm trying to do.
HI!
[loud thumping]
Mark: Whoa...
Oh, so that's how it's gonna be?! A good ol' fashioned knock 'n fight!
It that actually somebody on the other side of that?
It's jammed. Hmmmm, what a conundrum we're in.
I guess I'll venture on.
Oh, hi! What the Hell?
Hey. how's it going there?
WHO'S THERE?
Uh oh!
This ain't good
...What was that?
*distant voice talking in a foreign language*
Huh?
Say again?
I don't speak Spanish.
Alright...
Whoa hi! HEY!
Dun run away from me...
Ooh, you gotta mach-ete [pronounced incorrectly]
Alright..bye buddy...
I didn't notice these guys before.
[off-camera woman's scream]
[man's voice] "Jesus."
I-Is that Lynn? That's not good...
Hello!
Do you have my wife?
It's good that there - [laughs] it's good to know that there are family people around here.
[subtle, off-screen voices]
[voices continue]
[woman screaming off-screen]
[Markiplier] Ugh.
Ugh.
What is that?
[character makes gagging noises]
Ugh.
Okay
Well I seem to be in the thick of trouble.
Okay, so from what I can interpret this- [door slams shut]
And what I've seen before, this is like a commune
or s-something way back in the back areas.
Hello?
I saw you in there.
Oh!
Wow!
I honestly didn't expect that to open.
...okay.
[excited] Hi buddy! How you doin'?
You in charge? You seem to have a halo
but you don't seem like the type of person that deserving of a halo...
[mumbled] I'll reload the battery in a second.
I just want to make sure that I get to absolutely everything here.
[louder] 'cause I don't want to miss out!
'Cause I'm -- this is like the -- oh?
My God!
What happened here?!
Ew, gah - why is there a spray?
[disgusted noises]
I don't wanna know!
Maybe I should hide in the closet
but I don't have enough time for that.
We got to go!
We got places to beee.
[quietly] Hello?
Ah.
Is there someone over there?
No? Ok.
Alright then.
Ooh, shit.
That's comforting.
Okay.
Let me just check this door
"To open windows"?
[birds cawing, wings flapping] AH FUCK YOU!
Hi.
Okay. I don't think that was there before
or maybe it was and I missed out on it.
I don't really know.
Probably did.
I apologize if I get jump scared by things that I got scared by already.
Ugh.
Such a big baby.
Who is --
[freaked out] who's steppin' out there?!?
Who's steppin'?
Okay.
Let's move on.
Ooh.
That looks nice.
Wait, was that a door-- was that door slightly ajar? It was, okay.
Hello?
Hi.
'kay what's the point of this then?
[shaking doorknob]
Oh there is no point!
Oh, okay, never mind, then.
Alright.
Let's get a move on!
You only got [indiscernable mumbling] few places to be..
Hueh.
Okay.
LYNN!
I'm coming for yo- [disturbed noises]
[quieter] comin' for you very slowly!
Hi.
*rustling in the trees*
Ooh, hey.
Ooh, hey..
*more rustling*
Alrighty, then.
Someone just burp?
Why is someone burping in the woods?
Euh, it's a boomer!
A boomer is coming for us.
[improper pronunciation of latin sign] "Satan Inimical God"
Hi.
How you doin'?
Nice slogan.
Are you the three-eyed raven?
Alright here we go.
Oh I remember this part!
Oh, this part's bad.
Ooh-ooh this part's bad.
Okay, so,
it took me a while to fully comprehend what the hell happened
when I was playing this at PAX,
But, uh - oooh.
Oof.
That's not a good sign.
So, notice the, uh, euh.
The 'THIS'.
Then the blood.
Whatever the hell this is.
Okay.
*incorrect pronunciation* "Sacrificium"
"Annuntiavi"
That's a lot of detail to put into this.
Oh my God.
"Listopad"
Alright. But this isn't the fucked up part.
The fucked up part's over here.
[unhappy groaning]
It's bad.
It's literally, literally.
It's like - I'm not gonna lie,
I'm pretty sure that's a pit of dead babies.
Like it's... this game is going for fucked up
and it reaches it
and the worst part is,
you gotta...
You gotta walk across it...
*crunching/squishing noises as he walks across*
[disgusted noises]
Euhh.
Euuhh.
'cause I know,
I know Outlast has always been about brutality..
Oh! Great symbolism here.
Oh with the well.
And I'm pretty sure I thought about this when I came over here
Love-- [is cut off]
[young girl's indistinct voice]
Wait, who said that?
Who's talking?!
[young girl's voice]
I don't remember there being a voice before.
Huh, I wonder if I should look face first
into the well!
Huh!
Maybe that's an intelligent decision to make
in a town of horrors!
Here we go!
Hey, I'll investigate this
with my eyeballs!
[Markiplier screeches]
And then
that happens.
[character screams]
So that was a smoker
that pulled me in there.
There was a boomer belching in the woods
And everything is going to shit.
So somehow,
I don't know how-
[reads screen] "Look behind...left ALT"
Hyaa!
Alrighty there.
No one's over there.
Is anybody over there?
Hello?
Hyaa!
Okay - [whispering child]
Hi.
You there.
Who's there?
[child whispering] "Don't let this happen..."
Don't let..  the 'thep'?
The, the what?
Wait, hang on.
Where am I?
There we go.
I need to go this way please
[child whispering] "I'm scared.."
So am I!
Back off!
We're all scared!
Stop comp-
[child whispering] "We're not alone, here..."
What'd you say?
I dunno what you said there
[child whispering]
Uh, what? Don't blink?
What is this?
[child whispering] "He's coming..."
Uh oh. [metal clanging]
Oh geez! [child screaming]
[screaming continues]
[child whispering] "Where are you?"
I'm in the vents.
Thank you very much.
I don't know why you feel the need to talk to me.
Little girl?
Ahhh shit.
Ow, my nose!
Alrighty then.
[ominous laughter]
So this is where things start to devolve
into madness.
Ow! Ooh, I got a boo-boo!
[mock crying]
[child whispering] "I'm scared..."
Yeah don't worry everything is in
in proportion.
Wow that didn't look good.
Alright.
Hello everybody.
Hi.
How you doin'?
Okay.
Well that didn't open.
Well what am I supposed to do? Over here?
Is this the one...
Okay there we go.
Yeah that's good.
That's a good...
I don't remember the lights being out! I thought the lights were on last time I came here.
[jiggling locked doorknob]
Okay.
So.
Um.
I made a mistake.
When I was playing the demo, in this area,
I did something that I was no supposed to do
and I'm gonna do it again!
Because I think that's more interesting
Then what - then what, what was supposedly 'supposed' to be done.
Which would've been intelligent.
[locker door creaks open]
Hi, oh hey..
Opening doors? Yawn-o-rama!
I'll pick up this weird music box!
'cause that never...
hurts anybody in any game, ever.
Oh hi.
Hey Lynn! I'm sooo bored.
Eh, boy.
Shut up, BITCH.
Oh geez.
Alright then.
Why am I doing this so slowly?
Okay that wasn't creepy at all.
[eerie music]
What was that? [jiggles locked doorknob]
That sounds bad.
[metal clanging]
[ominous laughter] Stop laughing!
It's not funny!
Oh geez [clanging continues]
Oh, woah, what was that?
Oh, hi. [clanging intensifies]
Oh, bad...this is bad. [ominous laughter]
Probably bad.
Probably bad!
I'm not gonna tell you the thing I did or did not do... [clanging intensifies]
Hi friend-
Ah! The fuck was that?!
What the fuck!
You guys saw that!
What the fuck was that?!
[clanging slowly stops]
Okay.
I don't remember that being there before.
Dah di di di do ['singing']
[all is quiet except for character's footfalls]
Okay?
[footsteps]
What de fuck?
[weak, airy, laughter]
It was-
AH!
[loud jumpscare]
FUCK ME!
Aw, God damn it.
Okay!
Yeah that's the thing!
See, what you're supposed to do, "apparently",
is hide!
'cause that would be smart.
But I ain't smart!
I'm the opposite of smart!
I'm exactly unsmart and I'm almost out of batteries over here.
So I gotta move!
Let's go go go!
OH!
Weird light, I'll step into you!
Ah, good, yes, very nice.
Uh huh.
Ah, there we go, that's what I was looking for.
Boink! [camera beep]
Alright, flip boop be doop boop boop ['singing']
[raspberry noise]
Alright.
So now we're moving on, to this next area.
I believe...
[child's scream close by] Oh hey!
How's it going there? [scream repeats]
Yeah, what up? Huh? I can scream too!
[Mark screams, mocking the child's scream]
Oh no...
Wait, to peek?
I should I'd known about this!
[laughs]
Why do so many of this desks have clean-up -- kleenex?
Er, sorry -- tissue brand facial tissue.
Wonder what's going on over here.
Hello.
That's always a comforting sign.
Ah! [metal clanging]
What the fuck was that?
Ah!
Yes, good! Very good!
HI!
Ohh. [Disturbed Markiplier noises] [odd whirring noises, squelches]
Hello.
Should I look up?
Hi! [whirring noises continue]
Take me with you!
No? Alright then.
I guess I'm on my own.
Huh, I wonder if there's anything... BEHIND ME?
[quietly] Alright...
Nee.
Woah, hello.
AH!
Hey, how's it going?
Well how you doin'? [sounds of fighting]
[man grunting, protesting]
[Attacker: "I'll bleed you, in the yard!]
[character screams, grunts]
Thank you.
Oh. Oh, that's right
I gotta run now!
[Markiplier screeches]
Oh geez, hi. I didn't notice you before!
I didn't notice a l-- oh God I'm stuck I'm stuck.
There we go, that's better
Welp I'm probably gonna die because I didn't get much of a headstart!
Out here is where I'd made a--[Markiplier screams]
Go in the woods! [man preaching on a recording]
[man on recording: "[indiscernible] in our midst"]
Uh huh.
[recorded man: "Give them a knife, a gun, a fist if it's all you got!"]
[recorded man: "God rejoices in the spilling of wicked blood".]
Uh huh.
Okay.
I gotta go.
Ah, okay, here - this is where I bugged out the game.
For some reason this didn't work before.
And for some reason - WOAAAH
Hey how's it going [Markiplier screeches]
I was only running in the - OH.
Okay this ain't good
Where am I going?
Where the frick am I going?
Over there?
Oh shit. [other voices]
Over there??
Ah shit.
Okay.
Ah geez.
They're right beh -- ah fuck!
Go faster!
I don't care if you're tired!
MOVE!
Move your fricking ass!
Oh, they're right behind me.
[Markipilier squeals]
There we go.
Woo.
Safe at last.
Oh man.
That was an adventure. HI!
Oh geez!
Oh hey!
Oh God.
[disgusted noises]
[Squelching, Markiplier whimpering]
[Markiplier whining]
Oh geez.
So anyway!
Yup!
[indistinct voices whispering]
[Mark groaning]
So yeah!
[whispering continues]
So...
Yeah.
That's why I don't think that's gonna be the character that you play
in Outlast 2
but that's probably
uh, setting the scene for the universe that they're in.
This obviously isn't going to be in the asylum anymore.
They wanted to emphasize that for the sequel.
But it looks...
phenomenal.
It's so 'Outlast'
definitely,
hundred percent, it is way 'Outlast'.
But it went from
in the first game
'cutting off a few fingers'
--which was bad!--
to 'removing your entire 'crotch-al' area!
[pained Markiplier noises]
That's 'no beuno'
No beuno [not good]...
No beuno.
So either way.
I cannot wait for the final game to come out, it's going to be amazing.
If you want to see the first Outlast, and the DLC
I'll put both in the annotations and the description.
Thank you everybody, so much, for watching!
And as always...
[sultry voice] I will see you,
in the next video.
Bye bye!
[other video commentaries] "...professional butt-wiper before I did Youtube." [screaming]
"...just the entrails of the fallen on your face..." [screaming]